britney spears she was busy dropping an
audio rant with new shocking claims
about her conservatorship and this
bombshell about oprah
i have offers to do interviews with
oprah and so many people lots and lots
of money but it's insane i don't want
any of it
i was told i was fat every day i had to
go to the gym i couldn't even smoke
cigarettes people on death row can smoke
cigarettes
brittany released and quickly made
private a dramatic 22-minute audio clip
on youtube the 40-year-old singer lashed
out at her family and might even spit in
their faces and shared new allegations
about her 13-year conservatorship i was
just like a robot honestly i just i
didn't give up anymore because i
couldn't go where i wanted to go i
couldn't have the nannies that i wanted
to have i couldn't have cash another
surprise britney who was placed on two
brief psychiatric lockdowns in 2008 also
claimed she was completely sober when
she was first hospitalized honestly
still to this day don't know what really
i did i literally spoke in a british
accent to a doctor to prescribe my
medication and three days later there
was a swap team in my home three
helicopters there was no drugs in my
system no alcohol nothing it was pure
abuse
britney's family has denied abuse
maintaining their only concern is
brittany's well-being brittany's a
sweetheart three hours after britt's
audio post her mom lin fired back
writing your rejections to the countless
times i have flown out and calls make me
feel hopeless i have tried everything
she went on to suggest that she and brit
discuss all this in private
so what's behind britney's outpouring of
emotion well the singer may be feeling a
new kind of confidence
[Music]
she gave elton john a shout out their
duet hit the top of itunes charts in
nearly 40 countries within hours of its
release last week i have an amazing song
right now with one of the most brilliant
men of our time and i'm so grateful
[Music]